hello everyone everyone can hear me at
the moment hello
uh sues thomas uh who we got wendy
torreira uh great to have you here and
marcel and lars and lars
and henrik and anders and alexander
and henrietta who's the host and uh and
the others who i miss thank you so much
for coming along to my talk today i hope
you can all
hear me okay uh if there's any technical
problems along the way i guess
just dive in and get them fixed as soon
as you can
and um just to make sure this goes as
well
as possible uh welcome back to ndc oslo
it's one of my
fav most favorite conferences in the
world i've had
such amazing times in in oslo over the
last
uh few years uh last year was a huge
highlight getting to play with dylan
beatty and the linebreakers on stage at
the party some of you might have been
there it was a great time but also be
honest
there and uh it's wonderful that the
conference has continued
in these difficult times through to this
situation
and fantastic that you've all come along
and attended and you come along to my
talk today and i'm really
very very happy that you're doing that
um
so and i look forward to all being back
together in person hopefully
uh this time next year in in oslo
uh so uh many of you um
will know my background i am a
researcher at microsoft research
and i am the designer of the f sharp
programming language
and i have also worked i guess the
consistent theme in
my work in the dot net and programming
languages space
has been to expand the role
of functional programming techniques
and functional programming languages uh
to to let these wonderful powerful
ideas become to spread
and to become a broader application
and uh to help
to help normalize them and disseminate
them into
broader programming experience and i
think we can see the results of that at
ndc oslo we have talks like functional
programming in c
sharp uh we we have a lot of talks on
like f sharp or functional techniques
and so on and
you can see it all the way through
generics and other things these things
are now spreading and becoming a totally
normal part of the programming landscape
and this is a
a wonderful thing but because that is my
work i tend to
drill down to quite fundamental issues
in programming things are
which go right to the core of how we we
deal with programming right down to the
programming language level
and one of those topics is the one i'm
going to be talking about today
and that's about how functional
programming
interacts with change and adaption
with increment with incremental
computation
and the context i'm going to be talking
about then is in the context of high
performance functional
uis and a lot of the work i'm going to
talk about today is actually based on
this incredible
f-sharp initiative called the aardvark
platform
and you can find out all about aardvark
i'll just bring up some of the uh
web pages here we go the aardvark
platform here at
advarkians.com you can get it started
you can get touch and you can join their
research community and these are awesome
libraries for interactive high
performance visual computing
and graphics applications and they're
nearly all done in f sharp they're often
c
sharp uh components or apis in there as
well
and um it's you can you can check out
who's using it the community the
components and so on and i really do
encourage you if you
interested in this space
because it's really mind-blowing what
they are doing there with dot-net and
with f-sharp
and get involved in in in that
initiative
it's a big thank you to thomas ortner
kyo kaza harold
steinlechner and uh other people
other advice contributors uh the way
someone i mentioned at the end
as well uh
right okay so what's the situation well
okay there's two aspects to this
situation one is the one of sort of high
performance
ui that i was talking about there's
another situation which is about this
theme of functional programming
expanding its range of application in
ways that we didn't initially expect
when we started things like f sharp but
we now understand just
that functional programming is even more
powerful than we ever thought
it was and even more applicable to a
whole range of
uh of programming problems so the world
of ui is developing i've used this slide
last year in my talk at ndc oslo if you
were here
uh and the the slide is between these
two views on designing user interfaces
and
and and they're roughly two categories
of user interface we're talking about
not that i've got the screen but there's
a high performance graphics kind of
applications i was talking about
just now now also these information rich
application
uh which is sort of line of business
applications
uh and so this is about how you design
the live business applications generally
you have these mvvm components uh
mvvm approach over on the left and we
have this mvu
approach over on the right and uh
mvvm is sort of the standard in the
industry today it's how the underlying
components work for things like wpf and
uwp
and zabra and forms and over in the
right you've got these new quite trendy
quite interesting
ways of doing things which is based on
this model view of that and they're very
different architectures over on the over
on the left you
generally use object oriented
programming and use mutable
programming models and you often do this
view in something like xaml
okay you've probably all done this kind
of work over on the right
and overall let me just close this down
over on the right we have uh
generally functional programming
approaches we have
immutable models underneath quite often
and the view is often done in the same
language or a mix between some markup
files
and the the um the view might be done in
a dsl
in f sharp or in another programming
language such as elm
okay so
okay just to compare how information
flows in in these two systems over on
the left
each of these components are mutable so
there's
actual state change going on in each of
them
and that it's very intrinsic to the
design it sort of influences the entire
design of the each of these components
you have a view
here where things are changing and you
have data binding messages going back
and forth
to the new model and then you have a
two-way binding here between the model
and the view model when the model is
perceived to be where the business logic
and data is so
we're all familiar with that
architecture and the model on the right
the information
flow is very different and it's the key
thing key phrase to remember is
univ unidirectional in
data flow so if information flows really
in one direction
around the loop so we start with the
model and the model is rendered by a
function into the view and the view
uh receives some messages or generates
some messages in response to user
interactions or from outside events
those get processed into an update it
generates a new model and you re-render
the view and that's the basic
information loop that's going on over on
the right
so i've been through this one and this
is another view the elm architecture
of the same thing you'll just see these
round and round unity information flow
diagrams in all the basic descriptions
of the elm architecture or anything
involving unidirectional data flow
and just to say that this idea that we
move away
from objects of mutation over in the
mvvm world or at least
we have might have that underneath but
on top we build
something that uses unidirectional data
flow
these this idea of uni directional data
flow in all its variations
is becoming almost ubiquitous in the
world of inter interface
development and there are quite a few
different variations on this and this is
in uh and this is quite key to
understand
people use the term mvu generally using
it for uh
the the elm version of this where you
actually have an immutable model and you
and you have these pure a very pure
approach to this
but if you look at systems like swift ui
or you look at maui
uh or you look at fabulous from in the
sharp world you even look at react it
has elements of this in it and the and
this
way of doing user interface programming
is becoming more or less ubiquitous and
i actually talked about these ideas last
year at ndc
and these are now strongly contributing
to the future of dotneta.net ui
in the context of the maui project which
was recent the maori initiative it's
really the future of multi-platform ui
in the dot-net stack uh for at least
it's one
it's it's microsoft's uh sort of big new
initiative
in this area and you can see from the
blog post about maui
that they are enabling developers to
write fluent c
sharp and you will be able to do it in
fsharp as well to uh
ui to implement the model view mvu
pattern or a variation on that pattern
and it uses one way flow of data and
state management and a code first
development experience those are the key
parts of
mmvu right so that's the situation but
the big
the question i want to ask really is is
functional relevant to
high performance ui because there are
key
trade-offs in this in this mvu approach
and what do we mean by high performance
ui and this is actually a
a an application that is using uh
the techniques the adapt functional
adaptive data techniques i'll be talking
about today to do
high performance functional ui
and it's uh it's a visualizer due it's a
great it was one of those wonderful
applications of uh of coding for for you
know it's all to do with um
uh uh the
reconstructing the martian surface
images
based on the data that's coming from the
rovers
on the planet uh and um
you can find out a lot more about this
application in this wonderful talk
which i will link at the end of the talk
this is i almost
i almost canceled my talk and just
decided to play thomas ortner's talk
from gpu day 2019 the future of
computing graphics and data analysis
and in this talk uh thomas uh gives
a wonderful overview let me just
maximize this
a wonderful overview of how he's using
these techniques
for functional programming for high
performance data and
ui and let me just skip through some of
this uh and you can see some of the
applications
they're using it using there and what
and one of the key things in this area
is you're they're reaching for
functional programming
for those classical reasons that
you want to reduce your time to market
and you want to be able to crank out
high quality prototypes on a low budget
so they're looking for that
productivity of functional programming
in this
in this extremely complex and
technically challenging
domain okay so that's
our context here and that's the video
talk you can
go and watch okay so let's go back to
basics
now we've set the context for where the
areas in which we're trying to apply
functional programming we want it in
those information rich apps but we want
extreme versions of those
where uh you have incredible amounts of
information
in the application and you have high
rates of
change in the application
okay so uh just to get back to basics
here's a typical structure of an mvu app
we have the model from which a view is
generated up here
we have the messages which calls updates
to the model we have the initial state
of the for the model the initial model
and we have
the logic which updates the model and
that's in a sense all the business logic
and part of the wonder of mvu is that
you get to
uh you get to unit test these parts of
your code separately you can test all
your business logic
through this very and this is all
straight up pure functional
programming there might be some
interaction with some components on the
uh the outside some database components
and the likes and has some connection
handles
they will typically be stored in the
model as well
okay and then you have the key thing
which is the computation to
construct the view and uh and here we
have say so
if you're doing this then generate a
label otherwise generate a button and so
on and in in more detail
depending on the dsl you're using to
express your view
uh it will it will look like this we
have model we have
messages is the button pressed or not
the initial model
the button's not pressed we update the
model and then we have the view
which can be the view which is a dynamic
view it depends on whether the model is
pressed
so the entire view will change the
entire dom
tree that we have ultimately will have
to change
based on that button press and the
entire the entire view gets brought down
and an entire different view
might get brought up as each message is
processed
and the beauty about this as we said is
it's all dysfunctional programming uh
the ui
becomes calculation and the wonderful
thing when you think of functional
programming it's not all these abstract
ideas and everything
it's actually really something we do all
the way through school as we write down
calculation after calculation it's
algebra it's just
information and calculation rather than
state and mutation and so the whole ui
just becomes its calculation and because
because the information flow is
unidirectional
then then you can always track down
where information is being lost where
it's been gained where bugs are being
introduced and you can break it apart
each bit
you can break apart and unit tests
separately
and so and the views are
recomputed and then a shadow dom is
produced
it does a diff between the shadow and
the actual dom and apply some changes to
the actual dom
okay that's beautiful but well we've got
an
issue here and this is really at the
heart of what what i've really been
boiling
getting towards because are you serious
that we are going to use functional
programming
for rapid update data intense
interactive ui
and you look at that you need to say you
can't possibly
be serious that that that this approach
which we've just talked about is going
to be suitable for high performance ui
because you're recalculating the view
as you uh even if you
are recalculating a shadow view then
and doing a diff you still have to do
that stiffing
process it's still computationally
intensive in a sense
on each update to work out what needs
to change you might it's very
declarative
but working out the incremental version
of that it's hard but
what if we change a question so that so
so the cat we see our cat and we
everything and the
question is what if we're doing
incremental functional programming
for rapid update data index incremental
interactive ui okay so if we insert that
keyword incremental
then we uh we begin to consider that we
may perhaps
we are talking so metal and functional
what
even is that and that is really at the
heart of
of the talk today i've set the scene and
i've got the question
uh what is incremental and functional
when it really comes down to it
and just stop and think to yourself uh
take take a take take a moment to stop
and think
what word associations if someone comes
along to your customer comes along to
you and says hey we're going to do
we need an incremental xyz
uh we need to you know process process
new information as it comes in and
changes
and and you might be if you're
functionally trained you might be
thinking
event sourcing and that's good that's
that's very related to the techniques
i'm thinking about today
but if you're object-oriented trained
you will immediately be starting to
think about okay i'm going to have
objects i'm going to have mutable state
i'm going to be making incremental
updates i've got to be writing lots of
code to maintain that incremental state
along the way
and so if you do you might also be
thinking about okay we're going to have
a dependency graph
we're going to be doing asynchronous
update to that dependency graph we're
probably going to get ourselves into all
sorts of
currency problems and so on and that's
for me
it's interesting to do i i i went and
did
i made a word graph to myself copied out
some words and made this nice graphic
entirely not based on any information uh
except what's in my head about what it
makes me think when i hear the word
incremental i think update nodes
dependency graphs i think
mutation a static probably a static
graph
if i suddenly think oh my god it's going
to be a dynamic graph and incrementation
this is going to blow my mind
okay so it it is a complex space that
people that challenge people's
uh challenge people and i've got a
little secret for the functional
programmers as you sit
around your team and think
where are where are the mutable objects
and where is the kind of
static thinking where is the kind of
object orientation in the in the worst
many good aspects of object oriented
object programming but if you think
about object orientation kind of
thinking coming in
then one of the likely sources of
object immutable object thinking in your
team
is going to be to do with incremental
processing of results okay
and so part of what i want to get
through is
not just the situation but if you as a
functional programmer can
master incremental functional
programming
uh you will be able to do more
functional
everywhere and build better systems with
better reliability
at lower cost and um
you so this and and one area
you should learn is absolutely event
sourcing and as i said it's related
it's related to what i'm talking about
today and this library on the ui side of
this set of techniques uh
is uh is a similar
a similar core thing you can learn i
call it's like having a tool
in your tool belt to go and tackle many
different problems
uh in in the future okay so let's so
let's just
recap where we are using some slides
from the wonderful yaron minsky
your ui as an incremental computation so
this is the traditional model
of vdom that gets applied to the dom in
the view function
and traditionally in these mvu systems
you compare as the model changes you
compare
the vdoms that are produced you re-run
and generate the view function and then
you get a diff
and you apply it to the actual diamond
we all know that's what react does and
that's what many of these systems do
and uh but we are going but look at this
we're recomputing this this function
down below
here we are recomputing the v dom on
each
on each stage and yeah you recompute the
v dom this is the same question we asked
before
but drilling down to the more specific
you can't be serious
you incrementally can recompute the v
dom now we
are talking okay so we want to say if
there is a diff to the model
uh so we want this this to not be a
whole new model but we want to know what
this actual diff is
then we compute a diff to the v dom and
we
and we run all the way through and this
kind of says well we're not just going
to be doing
mvu which is functional functional
functional functional
model functional view functional update
and this is what elm fabulous and elmish
and others
do we actually want a variation on it
which i'll call sort of delta mvu
which is a delta to the model a delta
to the view a delta gets propagated
through the update
and a delta to the view
okay so so to get down to the question
we're asking incremental plus functional
what even is that
one place you can go and there are
actually many
actual technologies which fit in this
particular intersection
in software design uh there
and and this is not the bill it's
an end-all of it but one place you can
go to learn about it
is fsharp.data.adaptive and i
really like this library and that's why
i'm drilling into it on this
in this talk because it exactly captures
uh this intersection between functional
and
and incremental for the working.net
programmer you can use this library from
c-sharp as well
it has a it has a design api designed
for use from c-sharp
and that is that is great appropriate
set of extension methods and the like
and uh please uh
you know try out this library contribute
to it it's just coming up to version 1.0
it's a very high quality library i've
been using it uh and
it's extremely well tested based on code
from the advanced
who i mentioned before and it really
and what i like is that it's not um
it's not tied into any other ui
framework or anything it's used by those
things but it's just conceptually
independent and you get to learn the
intersection of techniques and i think
it's one of those things
actually digging into the code if you're
if you're an f sharp programmer it's
actually
really interesting experience as well
because uh
it it it you learn something from that
you learn a set of new techniques
okay so let's look at how this works and
remember the key thing is we want the
fsharp.data programming model as in
like f-sharp dot uh collections of lists
and it could be called their
shop.collections.adaptive
actually rather national.adaptive so we
have these collections like fsharp lists
we know as f sharp programmers you take
a list and you map it and you get a new
list you can filter that list you can
sum that list we have all this wonderful
set of
operators you can use to take functional
data and transform and shape
and reduce it out and and
that programming model is consistent for
lists it's consistent for arrays it's
into sequences and for sets and for maps
and so on and these collections
all support the same set of operations
and uh having done some c-sharp
programming
recently i mean i know there's c-sharp
link but but
the the actually the f-sharp uh
functional collection programming model
is actually
really nice and really consistent across
all these different types
so something that all f sharp
programmers absolutely know
and love so that's
uh that's that model and we all
given you know that model you want a
really simple leap
step towards the incrementalization of
that model
and and that is we're going to have an
adaptive
list which you can map and we're going
to have an adaptive filter
and we're going to have an adaptive sum
it's the same programming model you just
sort of put
a on the front and
and internally instead of having a list
of data you have the propagations of
delta of changes
to that list and you can
as you have your own functional
collections
uh and your own yeah your own functional
data types your own models and the like
you can actually
write the same you can implement your
own adaptive version
of these of this programming model
okay so uh continuing on uh let's just
walk through
some basics of how this actually works
in practice i'm going to do that
in visual studio code and
i'm going to just so i have ionide
installed in visual studio code
i'm using fsharp.net core
programming down below fsharp
interactive
and here is some functional programming
so let's just do the
the usual let's just create a list of
ten thousand elements
here and we're going to multiply each
element of the
list to generate a new list like this
and we have a new list whether it's
multiplied by 10
10 20 30. okay so it's the usual
information
and calculation here and we have
except i'm actually going to put a print
uh down below so you can see 10
000 prints coming out there
okay and we have that and i just we have
some information we'll do a
transformation on that information to
multiply it up by 10
again so we have our two steps in the
pipeline
and then we will sum that result
up except what did i do wrong here
[Music]
okay i'll drop this down to a thousand
okay i have the result down down there
okay uh now we can put those steps to
that pipeline up and we can take the
input list here coming in and we can
have a function that computes those
results uh with a function taking an
integer list and reducing it down to an
integer
and we compute the results here actually
i was going to drop this down to ten
thousand
here
and i'll do it again drop it down to it
down to a thousand
okay so now what if the result is
actually
what if this list actually changes
that's and that's the kind of thing we
want to get down to is what if your
input
actually has one less element in it say
the element
five is removed so we have the
list from this up to up to a thousand
here and we'll put that in brackets
here we'll get rid of this filter
here and that's now our input and we get
a different result
coming out as you can expect it's
reduced but you'll notice that we're
re-computing
all the work every time we had one item
removed from that list
and there was an incremental change
where five disappeared
and you think to yourself how would i
adapt that how would i avoid
doing that work all over again
okay that is a key problem it's like
suddenly programming has become hard
right or
from what looks like so trivial or just
multiplying by 10 and multiplying by
10 and adding things up and suddenly
i don't want to do all that work again
in response to that
change of that removal of five and you
think to yourself
oh my god this is going to be really
quite tricky all that state i'm going to
have to maintain
in order to make sure i don't redo that
work
okay so now let's do this in the
adaptive
version of that so we have an adaptive
input so
this is the initial uh initial
uh state of the of the the the initial
input into our adaption
and uh we were using lists up above
we're going to use a
set here and we do a map and we do a map
over that adaptive set and we do an
adaptive sum so we've started off with
our input and we're doing our adaption
and it's it's
effectively functional programming a
functional transformation
and we observe the result at the end
actually i was going to change
this down to a thousand here
just uh let that run through
and it will have the same problem we had
before
and we'll do that some and we'll take a
look at the result
and the result is sure enough it's
correct but now something changes the
change comes into the system
and changes are still ultimately at the
fringes of the system you still have a
change being made
imperatively it's and then you have this
functional flow all the way through
and then you have a change being
observed okay so you still have an
imperative changes at the edges of the
system but the core of your code
is still a functional transformation
and uh we so we had
uh removing the element and now we do
the force here
you'll notice the result has come back
and absolutely
no nothing has
been recomputed okay now let's try that
again and say how what the heck happened
okay so let's add a new input
i'd add the input 20 000 into the set of
of results and we re-observe wow
so all that work that we did to compute
the first result up here which did all
those
printing out of 10 000 things all of
that
none of that got all of that got saved
somehow
okay in in in whatever data flow is
going on whatever
however things are being computed and
you can look up the details in that
shop.data.adaptive about how this works
all of that got uh got got recorded and
saved and all those intermediate tables
to work out what to do and what not to
do
when we removed the result it just said
um what did it do
it said okay so this result and it had
recorded
how that five had gone through this
mapping and given us 500
and it just said some i have to change a
sum result
in response to a change for what's
coming in well i just subtract it off
okay so i did the subtraction there then
when we did the addition well it
multiplied that up
it actually did do those steps you can
see those steps being done
a new element comes in it says hmm i've
got a new element
and we're doing a map okay work that out
and then we get to the sum
it's a new element in the sum so i'll
just add it on okay so it's
incrementalized
the entire functional declarative
computation uh in
it it has built up an incremental
version
of that that can respond to add and
remove
events okay so that's the core idea
of let me switch across
to uh fsharp.data.adaptive and here is
the the
the library actual.adaptive and adaptive
values and it'll run you through
that it'll run you through how to build
a little excel spreadsheet uh which
sort of does incremental update and
computation or things that are like a
code version of an excel
spreadsheet and you can look at how you
can build up these
graphs of uh what feel like graphs of
adaptive computation now crucially these
graphs can also have dynamic
dependencies they don't have to be
merely static
uh and we'll we can talk about that in
just a moment
so just say fsharp.data.adaptive your
data as incremental
computation okay so over on the left you
have
your usual f sharp immutable data and
over on the right i've given the
corresponding thing for your adaptive
version of your data so where you have
an integer you'll have an adaptive value
of an integer and
over on the left you have a list you
have an adaptive list a set you have an
adaptive set a map you have an adaptive
map
and uh if you have a an actual list of
values you'll write a list
one two three on the right if you have a
computation so for instance
uh you're treating time as an adaptive
value they're 1.0 plus
now.seconds you'll write a val and
you'll get the current time
using the f sharp workflow syntax left
bang t equals
now and you will take t.seconds and add
it
one and use a return and over on the
right you've seen the pipeline just like
we just had
over on the left sorry you have a list
dot
map filter and sum and you have a list
map filter and so on
okay so you can see how you can take
function functional f sharp functional
code and do a fairly straightforward
translation
over on the right until you have your
adaptive
version of your code okay
but we we're talking user interfaces and
you say oh this is all just lists and
some
lists and maps and sets and things okay
and uh so what about
the user interface uh okay well
um let's just talk about the okay so
because ultimately we're going to do
you have to compute a view in the mvu
programming model so what is the dom
as data and this is a typical f sharp
programming model of
dom as data you each dom node
has i an id uh it has a set of
attributes uh it's a map from a
functional map from strings to some kind
of attribute value
and it has a set of children and that is
a tree of data that is a full
declaration in f sharp for a typical dom
uh a dom tree nice and simple recursive
uh structure okay so
what is the dom as adaptive data and
this is a kind of thing you have to
learn when using this library when you
have some data structure you say
so you you prototype out your code in
terms of
beautiful pure functional programming
and then you say i want to
incrementalize that
and you say where are the key points uh
where you need
to insert your incrementalization and
those usually come down to the insertion
of these
a this magical a letter for adaptive at
exactly the right places
so in the dom node you now have an each
dom has
an adaptive map of attributes
what does that mean that means your dom
node its attributes could change
over time okay that it did there will be
these deltas
of changes to these maps additions of
attributes
changes of attributes removals of
flowing up through your dom node okay so
it becomes an adaptive
map at every single dom node now has an
adaptive map so as you have your view
each thing you get getting the
perspective of where your dom node can
change
your children of your dom node is now an
adaptive
list of children okay so what does that
mean you can have
new children it can have removed
children
it can change over time and don't forget
they they themselves
it's a recursive structure going all the
way down you have adaption
all the way down all the way down your
stack of turtles can
change anywhere along the way
okay so here we have in a four
line declaration we have a declaration
of
one of the most difficult to implement
programming language structures a tree
that adapts and changes over
time and where there's a a a coherent
notion of what are the deltas
to that tree okay so
you now you now have an adaptive
dom that simple now there there is
complexity here
but in terms of the use underneath
absolutely
and maintain in this thing the way this
the way the adaptive maps
are implemented and maintained is
absolutely key which is why it's in this
wonderful library called
shop.data.adaptive this is a recursive
adaptive type
the whole shape of the tree might change
and adapt
okay so when you have an adaptive dom
that is the key those four lined data
structure you see there
is the absolute magic that's sitting
inside a high performance functional
web ui okay and just to say
uh that it's
it's not just about the dom the mvu
programming model tends to focus
on the dom but actually if you have
adaptive scene graphs
then you'll have high performance
functional graphics uis
and uh that's what's covered in the
aardvark platform it's
thankfully the key idea that at the core
of a lot of what aardvark is doing is
you have this
adaptive scene graph and uh
you can go and look at aardvark okay
so right uh
just to say okay let's say we have the
adaptive dom
on the left and i haven't really
represented the change that's happening
to that
thing and the deltas that are happening
but i've talked about it children get
added children get removed
attributes change the whole shape of the
tree tree can
kind of change as things go on uh
now and it's not a static graph okay
it's absolutely a dynamic thing so you
do full-on dynamic ui
with this now the actual code
uh that's in these frameworks that sort
of consumes
these changes ultimately you have to l
in some sense
listen to the changes coming from one of
these adaptive
collections or one of these adaptive
data structures and ultimately you have
to make
changes to the real dom now you don't
have to do this in your
as a user of this thing but if you're
going to
work with fsharp.data.adaptive you might
and you and build interesting new data
structures you might have to
write this kind of code that listens to
changes on an adaptive thing and makes
changes to an actual thing and it's
actually
uh interesting exercise and puzzle and
once you solve it you encapsulate that
listener
and it just becomes a simple combinator
which says sort of propagate changes
from here
to here and you have this sort of
corresponding
uh set of listeners which sort of listen
into the
changes coming over from the left and
make a
corresponding actual mutations actual
changes over on the right and
uh there are samples in
fsharp.data.adapter there's some pull
requests skipping those samples
as well listing in at the edges okay so
what have we gained by moving to
adaptive functional data you get
very very minimal recomputation and
update you already saw that minimal
recomputation for that sum
that corresponds through the entire ui
programming as well
adaptive data can have dynamic shape and
dependencies you're not being tied into
this static thinking
but it can have this sort of static
outer part
for performance that is you can make
sure you're not re-cue
there is a risk here that you end up
recreating the entire adaptive part
in response to just one little change
anywhere in the graph and you have to be
aware of some techniques for
avoiding that so you have this sort of
static outer outer part
and also there's this thing that these
adaptive
this adaptive data is recomputed on
demand
okay and that is actually critical in
especially in the context of these
adaptive scene graphs because of course
you only have one in your typical game
or visualizer of the kinds we've been
seeing earlier on
you only have one part of the martian
surface that you're looking at even
though you've actually got this huge
information space
available and you want to only compute
that that part on the
demand as things change through your
user interface or as the camera changes
through your views okay and just how
does it actually look
in code in a typical delta mvu app an
incrementalized mpu
then you have a model you have an update
stay the same
uh you have this interesting bit of code
automatically synthesized which is
generates from your functional model
this tool called adaptify
uh it's part of the uh fsharp.
sort of tool chain gives you an adaptive
model
uh so where your individual adaptive
values like is the button pressed
goes from being purely functional to an
adaptive functional and it gives you a
thing which diffs out the models to
compare those two models so these parts
actually stay purely functional but it's
only the view which is written with
respect to the adaptive
model so you still get to do all the
nice functional programming but the
delta
you get the deltas on the views and the
view now becomes a thing which is built
on the adaptive model and sort of
listens to changes to that adaptive
model
and you in this case it's a adaptive
value which
when the model is pressed then you'll
get a change uh
in the appropriate view and um
yeah that this is a typical way that
you'll see
the in things like uh the adaptive
uh elmish mbu programming models
this is the kind of code you will be
typically seeing
the adaptive view okay
okay so uh i am actually close to
finished i
i will be finished well ahead of time
the
summary of the whole talk is really that
that mvu is a beautiful programming
model you see it's starting to influence
you know in swift ui you see it in maui
ui uh
and you see it in elm initially it's
absolutely amazing for information rich
apps but
and but it does have performance issues
for high performance ui and extremely
data-rich ui
and so you're beginning to see these
variations on mvu
which allow adaptive functional data to
make this
mvu point of view this functional point
of view relevant to amazing high
performance ui
uh and just some of the examples uh that
have been done with the aardvark
platform i've mentioned that the
robotics viewer on the right
uh you mentioned this high quality light
lighting simulation
overseeing graphs uh this is
some of the best visualization research
i mean there's a lot going on in these
kind of areas but it's just
they're cranking up these incredibly
high uh incredible applications with
high productivity
of extremely complex data sets uh based
on what they're doing in the yardback
aardvark platform
so uh um and the other
part yeah that's the high level
conceptual thing that you'll see
repeated in many different settings over
the next 10 or 20 years
is this thing about adaptive functional
data making
it relevant but if you want to actually
use adaptive functional data today
there are several different options
floating around the.net space
uh some of the tool chain some of the
the mvu systems like maui have
things actually incorporated uh
some some some of these elements
actually sort of incorporated into maui
itself uh but if if you if you want to
actually use the general notion of
functional adaptive data today
you can do that with
fsharp.data.adaptive and get involved
and contribute to that library
as well and um and and build things
on on top of it it really is an amazing
bit of technology some resources for you
uh
uh there's uh three talks from the
advarchians guillock harza functional
adventures on high performance computer
graphics
you have the thomas ortner talk which i
mentioned before functional programming
boosting scientific and industrial
research
and this uh one from harold steinlechner
and georg harza on functional
programming versus efficiency a lot of
these things about incrementality
we talk about also other ways to get
super high performance
uh using your functional programming
language
and uh there's an entire course on this
uh from one of the austrian universities
and
uh we have the repos here the aardvark
platform
and f sharp.data.adaptive